we're going to begin with breaking news
out of the u.s where president joe
biden's announced the killing of abu
ibrahim al-hashimi okareshi the leader
of isil by american special forces in
syria in a statement joe biden says last
night at my direction u.s military
forces in the northwest of syria
successfully undertook a
counter-terrorism operation to protect
the american people and our allies and
make the world a safer place thanks to
the skill and bravery of our armed
forces we have taken off the battlefield
the leader of isis all americans have
returned safely from the operation
well cinnamon koscium is standing by in
istanbul first let's bring in our white
house correspondent kimberly hawker
kimberly the white house is obviously
very pleased with this operation but
there are going to be some questions to
be asked
yeah the white house characterizing this
as a successful operation and notable in
the president's statement that he
released is that all of the u.s special
forces
that were involved in this operation
returned back safely but the same cannot
be said for the civilians on the ground
we know that there are at least more
than a dozen casualties and among them
children and so that is of grave concern
to many who have been watching this
waking up to this news in the united
states
given the fact that
this is a bit of a surprise on
a number of counts the not only the fact
that there are still u.s operations in
syria which many will be unfamiliar with
but also the fact that the united states
was not more careful more
surgical in this operation and allowing
it to be more precise
and preventing these civilian deaths so
this is something that the u.s military
will have to explain but it's also
something the u.s president will have to
explain why
uh he's continued this trump-era policy
donald trump his predecessor uh saying
that most of the u.s troops were out of
syria but as the commander-in-chief joe
biden obviously carrying on some of
those policies keeping those troops in
place
even if in a very small number he'll
have to explain why that is why he
decided to
take out the isil leader now
and at the same time risk innocent lives
and so we're expecting that statement
from the u.s president he will be
speaking from the roosevelt room of the
white house we expect that to happen at
the bottom of the hour in the interim
already the white house has released on
social media a photograph
of the national security team which
includes the vice president kamala
harris sitting alongside joe biden as
they watch this operation
be conducted in what we suspect is the
secure location
of the white house where the types of
operations are observed that is now
public
again a little bit not unusual for these
types of photographs to be released but
again
hardly a reason for celebration given
the fact that there is uh there are
casualties they do include children
although the white house claiming this
is a victory the fact that an isil
leader has been killed in this operation
yeah as you say um kimberly the the
those criticisms about um
additional casualties when attacks like
this are carried out are often leveled
at the u.s particularly in relation to
drone attacks this one as we understand
it and of course
information is fairly scant at the
moment seems to have involved
helicopters and troops on the ground the
helicopters we believe broadcasting some
sort of message in arabic to people to
evacuate the house before
any action took place the suggestion
might be that this is at least some
attempt by the u.s to try to minimize
those casualties but as you say in this
case it's not really worked
well and human rights activists would
take issue with that
and argue that you know how much can a
child be expected to comprehend
the notices that are given by military
professionals as a mother i can tell you
uh that this is something this is a very
tall expectation
of a young child and so uh there it
really begs the question of just how
prepared you one can expect a child to
be and so these are the criticisms
legitimate ones at that and so we do
know that these are questions the
military's going to have to answer in
fact we expect that the head of centcom
we understand uh and this is subject to
change but the head of centcom is
expected to be in the united states
potentially in washington uh on friday
and whether or not his schedule will
include a public briefing is still uh
open to question but we're certainly
watching to see if there will be further
briefings and updates from the pentagon
where there can be some clarity about
why this was not uh
more skillfully conducted to avoid these
civilian casualties given the fact that
we know that innocent lives were lost
kimberly given your experience of
watching how both sides of the houses
are are going to have been dealing with
these situations in the past is there
any way of speculating what kind of
reaction
um
senators and congress people are going
to have in response to this news
well what we're seeing increasingly is a
younger more diverse
uh population on capitol hill we're
seeing
uh sort of the traditional older
hawkish type
typically conservative but not always
members of congress who would in the
past 20 years be supportive of what we
know as the military-industrial complex
of the american war machine
not getting the same sort of support
that they would have in the past and so
uh it's likely that there is going to be
a strong course of criticism about this
attack coming from some of the younger
members of congress springing to mind
will be some of the
young democratic members like ilhan omar
of minnesota or even
alexandria ocasio-cortez from the
state of new york
who have been very vocal and critical
about
some of the american apparatus overseas
in these foreign conflicts that so often
disproportionately
cost
human lives and so
i don't think that we're going to see as
much support on capitol hill and we're
certainly not going to see it from the
younger more diverse voting public that
has
in the case of even my own son in his
who's 20 years old knows nothing but
conflict
and was born 10 days after 9 11 and and
knows a generation of war there simply
isn't the support that there was 20
years ago and the tolerance that there
was
20 years ago for uh this ongoing
conflict and so uh one more point of
cynicism that you see increasingly here
in the united states is when the economy
is bad
there's often this argument that
governments like to
create a war to get the economy going
again i'm not suggesting this but
certainly you will see that on social
media
as a means of injecting vigor into the
economy creating jobs certainly that has
been a criticism of the military and
industrial complex uh for longer than 20
years and certainly you will see that
raised again given the fact that this is
a struggling uh administration that is
facing challenges with inflation right
now that's our white house correspondent
kimberly hawk at kimberly as always
thank you very much let's go to cinema
costialo who's live for us in istanbul
cinema what more are you hearing about
what happened in syria
well rob actually there are uh
information coming which are conflicting
each other in a way because uh at first
uh we we thought the house of the abu
ibrahimal quraishi um was actually
destroyed during the
by the u.s operation but there are some
newspapers reporting that abu ibrahimal
qureshi blowed himself up
as the operation started also some
locals are saying the same thing but
what we know about uh the casualties is
that those 13 civilians who were killed
during this operation six of them are
children uh four of them are women and
three of them are
men
some suggest that those women some of
them were wise of
abu ibrahimal qureshi but of course we
need to wait for a confirmed information
coming uh from idlib and coming from the
united states sides as well
the before the operation we know that
the u.s military the u.s officials
actually coordinated uh with the turkish
side informing them about the
counter-terrorism operation that they
would be conducting so turks were also
aware
aware of the operation but we don't know
any information whether the turks or any
turkish drones uh in terms of uh
reconnaissance
were involved during this operation uh
what is interesting for the turkish side
is that the uh the location
of
croatia's house was just between three
to five kilometers deep from the turkish
syria border from uh antakyat city
of turkey and uh baghdadi the former
leader of isil again was killed through
such as a similar operation by the
united states special forces in 2019
and
that location was also close to the
turkish border so uh so far we don't
have any statements by the turkish side
any official statements uh suggesting
that they were aware from aware of this
operation but many experts on the
turkish national televisions have
already started to
discuss the possible implications of
such an operation by the turkish border
because it creates another national
security issue for turkey in terms of
possible
civilian influx to the borders in terms
of uh
the
fighter groups the that are listed as
terrorists by the united states coming a
close by the turkish border these are
all questions that are being discussed
on the turkish media right now yeah
someone can imagine that that
the countries neighboring syria are
going to be watching this very carefully
to see what kind of response there might
be uh from isil within syria um is there
any indication and i know it's very
early but is there any indication of the
any rising of tension within syria how
groups might respond
uh well i have been following the news
as uh as they broke uh now uh people are
curious because uh many
in turkey in terms of military experts
they expect a respond by isil
towards either
some of the
some of the groups that are close to
united states or moderate with the
united states
or the pkk
the
kurdish
pyd let me say the syrian kurdish
fighter group and
turks have been suggesting that
turkey is the only country
in reality on the ground fighting with
isil but
since the turkish president is in
ukraine right now uh having talks with
the uh ukrainian president about the
tension uh by the uh by ukraine russia
border
it's been quiet uh
in ankara right now but of course uh
we we know that uh the ice the
isil group has been fragmented and there
are other groups inside idlib there have
been operations by the us against
horacetine and some other groups as well
uh we will need to watch and see uh what
kind of reactions will come uh from
uh from those groups but i have to say
that those people that i have spoken in
idlib they are terrified because atma is
a very dense area just by the turkish
border hundreds of thousands of uh
civilians are living there most of them
have been already displaced during this
uh syrian civil war and there are nearly
3.5 million civilians residing inside
idlib region so these kinds of
operations uh in in some way is
relieving but on the other side this is
also
a threat for the civilians because now
they know that some cells can can find
refuge among themselves and they can be
targeted uh
collaterally during counter-terrorism
operations and this is very close to the
turkish border which also carries their
risk of another refugee influx as i said
before
cinnamon thanks very much indeed
talking to us from istanbul i want to
bring in michael pregen he's a senior
middle east analyst at hudson institute
he's a former u.s intelligence officer
he's joining us by skype from washington
d.c thanks very much indeed for being
with us on al jazeera how is this likely
to affect the operations of isil
well i think it's a significant strike
i i
we see leadership degradation after
baghdadi was killed
most people didn't even know
who karashi was no nobody has really
been able to you know if you ask someone
who's the leader of isis they wouldn't
be able to tell you they'll be able to
tell you today because he's dead
but as far as isis operations
they're still alive they're still
capable of conducting cross-border
operations into iraq
and also have a presence in syria
so they're looking for a new leader and
any time a terrorist organization is
looking for a new leader
it's it's it's an opportunity for for
intelligence
services to find out and and monitor
that
and the proximity to the turkish border
we would expect turkish intelligence to
know who that leader is going to be
we would have expected turkish
intelligence to know where karashi was
because this is the same area where
baghdadi was killed in close proximity
about 20 20 kilometers away
so this is an opportunity for
intelligence services to be able to
look at the competition for leadership
uh in isis that always creates a an
opportunity to target more leaders but i
think there'll be degradation initially
with isis much like we saw after
baghdadi's death
the element of intelligence is
interesting because if as you say this
is an opportunity for intelligence
services to start getting the lie of the
land and who's involved and so on one
would imagine that they were able to do
that when um
uh
was originally being put into place but
if i understand you correctly it was
only when he eventually materialized on
the scene that people realized who he
was and that he was actually the
successor so is the is there
the intelligence that effort actually
going to be able to achieve anything
given that it wasn't really successful
the last time
well you know intelligence failures
happen when we don't have boots on the
ground i mean the best way to have intel
is to be out there talking to people and
the united states just doesn't have that
presence or that language capability to
do that
our turkish allies uh do they have
relationships with the groups in the
area this is an area where
you know uh jelani works you know the
leader of uh
well the nusra front they change their
name
whatever they call themselves now
it's an opportunity for
those countries that are concerned about
isis and isis resurgence
to get in there and establish their
human intelligence networks and find out
who the next leaders are uh right now in
the u.s intelligence community they're
probably ranking four successors and and
watching the competition and the iraqi
government they have a good intel
network
they'll be able to help us with that
and uh
should be able to give us some clarity
but as far as the strike itself if i
could talk to the civilian casualties
let me know if you want to talk about
yeah absolutely let's talk about i want
to talk about the structure of isil uh
in a moment but let's talk about the uh
the strike itself given the fact that
this the strike was um to a certain
degree different to previous strikes
that we've seen predominantly the
previous strikes have been carried out
by drones this one was carried about by
helicopters carrying troops into uh into
syria
why do you think that was and why do you
think that this particular um targeting
warranted that action
i think the intent was to capture karash
let me just drink some water real quick
here
the intent of the operation was to
capture karashi uh there were people on
the ground for an hour communicating
with people inside the house to include
karashi
telling them to let the children and the
women out they wanted to capture him
he did not let the women and children
out
and the reason i say capture is you have
to remember that
vice president biden was against the
obama raid that
that
was designed to kill or capture osama
bin laden he was against that so this is
his opportunity to do a redo to do it
right this time uh and
right would have been great this would
have been a great opportunity for the
white house if they would have been able
to capture him
to be able to say we've captured isis
later if you can't capture of course you
kill but there was an attempt to get the
people out uh karachi didn't let that
happen some reporters say it was he blew
himself up others say that because he
didn't come out the united states just
destroyed uh the building we don't know
yet we'll find out but this was a a redo
this was uh biden's attempt to redo
obadabad because he's been criticized so
much in the united states for being
against the raid that killed osama bin
laden this is an attempt to fix what
happened in afghanistan with that
absolute failure of a strike on that
civilian vehicle that killed civilians
this is an attempted redo now again the
united states will always weigh civilian
casualties if they know in fact that the
target is in the house and if we can
confirm that karashi was there
then it's going to be a strike that the
united states will always say yes to
unfortunately how do you think this is
going to play out
with
congress and senators and with the
american public
well because they killed karashi and
because he's the isis leader
unfortunately a lot of those young
diverse members of congress i i guess i
qualify as one of those old hawkish
conservative types um they don't have to
tell tell them who karachi was i mean
they don't they didn't know he was the
isis leader they didn't know his name
they will now but because
karashi was killed
there will not be outrage there's not
gonna be any outrage about the civilian
casualties
i've been asked on other programs this
morning you know what about what about
the civilian casualties and my advice to
to uh women is don't marry a terrorist
i just want to ask you very briefly one
final question about the the structure
of uh of isil because the immediate
comparison that those of us outside the
business if you like uh make is between
isil and the structure of al-qaeda now
as i understand al-qaeda is a very
fragmented organization to some degree
isil is as well but in a slightly
different way and just very briefly just
for the benefit of our audience and in
terms of the creation of a successor um
can you just give us an idea how that
what that structure is
so senior al-qaeda leadership ensured
that everybody who joined the
organization was a professional
understood islam understood what the
tenets of al-qaeda were
isis was different they would just take
anybody so that's the ranks so the
leadership is cultivated but the
leadership believes it should be in
iraqi later and that's been one of the
biggest uh
conflicts within the organization as
they continue to say that the leader of
isis should be in iraq
and that's a lot of uh competition with
other other jihadists who who believe
that they should be the leader
regardless of their their status their
you know where they're from
michael preaching it's really good to
get your thoughts on this and we
appreciate you being with us in al
jazeera so thank you very much indeed
for your time
thank you thanks for having me